sans transition place au football
américain
cc l'intersaison en ce moment plutôt
calme après logiquement pour les pour
les clubs de football américain en
france et pour en parler avec nous sur
ce plateau le président des templiers
d'elancourt
bonsoir genre agostinho souvent le foot
us ou le fou le football américain
plutôt de façon plus commune c'est le
sport ce sport spectacle c'est souvent
synonyme de ça et on est allé demander
du co saint quentinois un peu ce qu'ils
en pensaient de ce sport et la vision
que qu'ils avaient en attaque fort alors
pour faire réagir le président et le
chauffer à tout de suite pas grand chose
qu'au minimum
à vrai dire
je connais tout juste le club qui joue
ici là les templiers d'elancourt parce
que ces américains alors de base j'ai
pris là j'ai pris le rugby on va dire
comme comme sport de ce style là après
je connais pas les règles je connais pas
les joueurs
je vais tout juste cette équipe là
honnêtement rien de spécial aucune idée
ça me paraît un peu agressif comme comme
jeu c'est un beau sport disant c'est un
très bon sport y en a ici
voilà on enfile en cours que c'est joli
ça change un peu du foot français qu'on
voit beaucoup trop à la télé il ya
beaucoup de convoitises ont une bonne
image non c'est bien j'ai déjà des potes
qu'on vous fait j'ai fait du rugby tout
s'annonce pas mal c'est bien ben très
américain je dirais violent oui c'est
violent très très masculins 3 il faut
gommer américain je préfère le football
américain au foot
déjà il ya plus de contacts
on va dire et moi le foot perso j'aime
pas trop le foot foot j'aime le football
américain par contre enfin plutôt une
bonne image
maintenant il ajouté avec attention fut
navy en tout cas ça a mal commencé
violant ses violons au foot us non il ya
des contacts c'est sûr mais violent non
pas les jours pas du tout
with its assurément c'est assurément non
seulement des signes au tac il ya les
équipes de filles bien sûr c'est un vrai
sport du conte allemand à partir de 11
ans donc thonon s'est pas c'est pas tout
à fait prête à présent complètement
protégés dont il ya aucune violence dans
le football de la même classe et
l'intersaison la saison en général
américain en france arpents début
février et fin janvier
il ya une actualité brûlante actualité
brûlante on parle bien sûr du mercato
des transferts mais aux templiers
il ya eu la création des cheerleaders
je crois qu'elles sont avec nous ce soir
sur ce plateau
même la musique pour les inconvénients
usa bien anthony vous avez fait la
surprise depuis le début de l'émission
bonsoir mais moi êtes chez un leader on
est bien d'accompagner ce serait bien
d'accompagner va faire les présentations
vous en prie leslie donc à côté de la
droite de georges de président voilà oui
au niveau national 10 c'est l'autre côté
c'est maintenant entre le président du
malawi la voilà et à côté de moi j'y
vois là qui font partie donc de cette
équipe de cheerleaders
alors pourquoi l'en vide est venu comme
ça de de créer cette équipe parce que
c'est une première il n'avait pas
jusqu'à présent une aide ponctuelle mans
à l'occasion des matches de coupe
d'europe on a essayé d'installer une
équipe de cheerleaders
donc là il y avait pas ce qu'il y avait
une envie avait différentes filles qui
voulaient créer ça et ça soit un peu
plus développé au sein du sein du club
parce que maintenant en france il existe
des championnats régionaux des
championnats de france et c'est donc
voilà il verrait une réelle envie
c'était un manque au club
c'était un moment on en voit là on
essaie de compenser ce manque par deux
charmantes jeunes filles comme ça et on
voit pas les bons je regardais le cadre
est vraiment qu il en manque encore si
ce sont 10 actuellement
voilà vous
vous allez rester sur ce nombre passe au
général les pom pom girls on dit pas le
nom logiquement c'est long terme on
entend souvent mais c'est cheerleaders
sur l'hiver il ya une différence
elles sont sur le terrain elles sont
nombreuses sont beaucoup et aux
etats-unis edf elle doit être une
quarantaine c'est des professionnels
et/ou en france ça va se limiter je sais
pas où l'équipe a produit un petit mot
donc là on recrute encore donc s'il ya
des jeunes filles motivées
la tranche d'âge ses 18 25
donc il faudrait être danseuse voir
gymnastes il ya des pré-requis la somme
annoncée vous toutes les quatre vous
faites à la base de la danse ou la
gélatine exactement on s'improvise pas
charly bérard non chercher une
reconversion oui oui je cherchais donc
c'est vraiment la différence donc les
entrepôts bureaux comme on dit celle qui
agite le fait bien à bord on n'a pas vu
à l'image la différence entre les pom
pom girls qui agite tout simplement et
les shaders qui qui font donc des
chorégraphies des portes et des sceaux
et c'était un terrain qui anime donc les
matches c'est très fortement l'absent la
première des visions deux enfants foot
us en france d'avoir des cheerleaders
ça commence je crois que ma oui oui je
vais avoir la moitié des équipes qui
sont au fond dès maintenant au pape ou
bien au chaud non mais non c'est pas
beaucoup
c'était des propos bien que les autres
mais vrai johnny depp ça commence à me
lancer des défis aux autres saison
s'annonçait tendue et là les
chorégraphies sont déjà un peu en route
allison vous avez déjà un peu commencé
on vous entraîner beaucoup ça doit être
non ça va c'est deux heures par semaine
le vendredi soir de 20 heures à 22
heures mais on a une prof
professionnelle et à la fin elle a eu
plusieurs médailles en gymnastique
d'accord et il ya un style de musique
sur laquelle vous lancer je sais pas de
la housse de l'électro musique
d'actualité pour mettre la musique en
fond sonore et non un panier alors elles
vont accompagner l'équipe première
toute la saison c'est ça l'équipe
première sûrement mais l'autre équipe
également pourtant on jouera à domicile
ayant c'est ce partage plaisir donc
toutes les catégories pour y avoir droit
aux niveaux au niveau sportif les
objectifs cette année ça va être quoi
pour pour les pompiers
là on parle foot là oui c'est vrai que
je l'espère elles ont aussi des
objectifs et donc au niveau foot on
parle de l'élite
oui l'équipe premiers pas dans l'élite
rooney passe à terre c'est grave
sanction pour cette équipe et on est
monté en plus alors on vient de monter
justement donc là il faut qu'on
redécouvre le niveau qu'on avait pas ce
qu'on avait joué donc en deuxième
division l'année dernière donc là et on
va redécouvrir le niveau notre objectif
c'est de gagner la moitié des matchs et
dans l'est on va dire dans les deux ans
retrouvez notre statut qui était dans
les trois quatre meilleurs clubs
français
voilà grosso modo c'est ça on sait la
première année va être sûrement
difficile parce que tous les clubs tous
les ans remonte augmente un peu leur
niveau
on espère rattraper ce niveau là se
repositionner voilà
dans les quarts de finale du show quatre
ans pour rattraper ce niveau il ya des
transferts qui sont déjà en route je
crois que cet après midi il ya peut-être
une signature toute fraîche voilà voilà
il ya eu des transferts franco français
on va dire et là on est en finalisation
de la signature de l'auteur bacs
américains
donc voilà on y est je sais bien d'eau
qui est il vient de californie et il a
un gros avantage pour nous c'est ce que
je recherchais il a joué en serbie en
pologne
donc il a déjà fait deux saisons en
europe et connaît un peu les
caractéristiques du football américain
c'est pas la première fois que vous
faites venir un quarterback et
américains non ça c'est pas forcément
toujours très bien passé les années
précédentes mais justement
donc là il fallait cliquer l'expérience
du championnat européen voilà c'est ça
parce que bon aux états unis je joue
devant à 84 90 mille personnes
ils ont un statut vraiment particulier
contre kod quand ils sortent de
l'université il arrive en france et en
europe
dans le sport il est ce qu'il est donc
ce mémorable donc humains qui sont un
peu déçus on a été chaude et il ya deux
trois ans des gars qui voyait le niveau
et les installations et autres
donc là on préfère prendre quelqu'un qui
a un très bon et vous parce qu'on en
avait plusieurs vidéos qui a un très bon
niveau mais qui connaît déjà l'europe
cas voilà notre sport à 25 ans en france
c'est tout enfin 26 c'est vraiment un
sport jeune encore un sport jeune et au
niveau des structures du club
il ya des nouvelles sections peut-être
chez les béni oui oui donc on a trois
nouveautés cette année donc en mille et
chez rogers
elle vient de les mentionner vaesken sa
mission en cours les missions vous voyez
que cette émotion se demander pourquoi
donc voilà donc qu'on a créé également
ce timing section minimes
donc il va se positionner entre l'école
de foot parce qu'on prend les gamins à
partir de 9 ans pour l'école de foot et
les cadets c'est lui 13 saisons donc là
on a créé une section meaning c'est pour
les gamins de 11 13 ans donc là il
commence à casque épaulières
alors on va leur faire faire des
tournois et autres et la troisième
nouveauté c'est les templiers tv compris
aux bons en fin de compte on va donc
c'est on va diffuser sur dailymotion
d'autre part par internet surtout une
diffusion de nos matchs en direct à
domicile puis aura dit bien lire au
portage enfin la fan de la fin de nous
faire connaître et l'autre pour sceller
trois grosses nouveautés les chirurgiens
les minimes et tempétueux et on va juste
conclure sur les objectifs pour les
cheerleaders il ya des objectifs aussi
moi je le sais pas me mettre l'ambiance
au stade pendant les matches faire venir
le plus de monde possible
c'est vrai que bon ça motive un petit
peu et voilà merci beaucoup d'être venu
tous les cinq sur résultat on a rarement
autant de monde je crois
puis on suivra évidemment la saison des
templiers en équipe première les skill
jeunes et puis aussi les prouesses des
cheerleaders et vous pouvez partir en
mettant l'ambiance si vous voulez sur la
santé ya pas de combien
à travers le resteront très en retrait
vous pouvez participer à changer de ces
gens là si vous avez photo on n'aura pas
en principe ressources de la
chorégraphie il va falloir progresser
l'objectif c'est de monter une
chorégraphie pour ce plat autour de la
table on viendra surtout les voilà
basket à présent basket et très vite
sans transition est très très vite
il ya une équipe qui cartonnent en ce
début de saison c'est les féminines de
l'entente le chesnay versailles
elles sont en nationale 2 six matches
six journées de championnat et six
victoires elles sont tout simplement
invaincus
la recette de ce succès avec des images
de guillaume cance virginie aurensan
pivot
mais la firme ne se lancèrent pivot
elles sont invincibles
les joueuses de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles réaliste un début de
saison parfait cinq victoires pour 5
matches joués
un règne sans partage dû en partie aux
recrutements réalisés à l'intersaison
avec le renfort de deux joueuses
étrangères
la biélorusse à l'ena novikova et la
serbe gorille chappy et match mais
surtout celui de virginie aurensan
arrivé tout droit de nationale une cette
saison le danger peut venir tout autour
de la raquette et leur adaptation s'est
faite le temps darroze l'intégration
très bien même si on est un effectif
réduit
voilà de suite des petites des petits
moments un peu informelle avec des
petits apéritif
voilà des petites anniversaires fêtés
donc c'est ce qui aussi fait que le
groupe est plus soudé que qu'autres
choses je pense que ce niveau là de la
compétition c'est une très bonne bande
de copines on s'entend très bien et je
pense que c'est dû à ça les victoires du
samedi soir
depuis deux saisons le lc ville manque
de peu la montée en nationale une
avec ce départ idéal le proverbe jamais
deux sans trois ne doit pas s'appliquer
la saison est longue la saison et il
nous reste encore beaucoup de matches
notre objectif cette année de jouer les
play-offs
notre objectif est la montée et
ne reste encore beaucoup de joueuses de
l'est elle sévit depuis cinq ans cécile
dansèrent a pu voir la progression du
club
mais le risque de se voir trop belle
peut arriver vite surtout lorsque l'on
est invaincu après cinq journées
le tout c'est que ça continue parce que
bon c'est vrai qu'on a commencé par des
équipes peut-être je dirais pas plus
faible mais moins impressionnante que
que celle qu'on a justement comme le
week-end prochain donc c'est vrai que là
on va vraiment encore entamé les gros
matches et c'est là qu'on verra si
vraiment on peut on est capable de
répondre
premier test avec la réception de
glacières actuellement 3e du championnat
du haut résultat basket toujours oui les
féminines justement de le fcv se sont
encore imposés ce week-end sur le fil 74
à 72 face à l'union sportive de la
glacerie
malgré une première mi temps un peu en
demi-teinte grâce à leur défense
extraordinaire un bloc solide elles ont
étouffé petit à petit leurs adversaires
elles sont toujours leaders évidemment
de nationale b basket toujours parce
qu'elle est un jour chez les hommes
trappe
en ce moment il est un peu trop synonyme
de défaite les les trappistes se sont
inclinés face à saint brieuc samedi soir
sévèrement d'ailleurs 53 à 37 un gros
gros manque de réussite rendre ces liens
le très sévèrement
oui très sévèrement un gros gros manque
de réussite au tir pour les trappistes
qui reste toujours dans la zone rouge de
leur poule de nationale 2 saisons se
suivent et ne se ressemblent pas du côté
de trappes qui avait remporté tous ses
matches en fin de saison dernière l'as
elles sont pas sur la même dynamique
effectivement du roller hockey pour
conclure le rocare les chocs 5 dont on
avait reçu l'entraîneur la semaine
dernière ou bas se sont baladés tout
simplement à pont de metz ce week-end
lui buts à 0 de quoi effacer leur
défaite la semaine dernière un peu
surprise 4 buts à 3 merci qu'anthony
merci vous invite également sport qui
sont venus pour cette chronique ce soir
on vous retrouve lundi prochain même
horaire aux alentours de 18h15 en direct
pour un point complet sur les résultats
ce sera un peu plus calme vacances
obligent il y aura toujours de
l'actualité on va voir les cheerleaders
tous les coups des semaines oui ce sera
la rubrique des cheerleaders après merci
anthony on va passer à la culture à
présent avec tito martins le compositeur
interprète son premier album vient de
sortir on va en parler